if you're picking up Mass Effect  Andromeda make sure you know the type of  game you're getting I'm Tony this is a  GameSpot news update and for all the  Space Age Bioware news be sure to  subscribe it was suggested last year  that Andromeda might be an open-world  game but that's simply not the case  producer Michael gamble said as much in  an interview with official Xbox Magazine  quote I definitely wouldn't call  Andromeda in open-world game we like to  use the term exploration based game you  still have the concept of tight story  deliverance and all the great things you  come to expect with Mass Effect Mass  Effect Andromeda comes to ps4 Xbox one  and PC on March 21st if you want more  coverage in the meantime visit GameSpot  and check out our video on five ways to  make the multiplayer great and to keep  up with all the latest on Mass Effect  you're already in the right place